wow
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
un progetto da fuori di testa
esattamente ci hanno definito così
pionieri folli per quello che stiamo
facendo la verità è che non sapevamo di
esserlo
abbiamo semplicemente provato a fare
qualcosa in maniera diversa
abbiamo semplicemente
accettato il rischio di fallire
a quanti di noi nella vita è mancato il
coraggio di fare qualcosa
eppure esistono migliaia di storie da
raccontare di chi ha avuto la forza il
coraggio di gettare il cuore oltre
l'ostacolo alla ricerca di qualcosa di
grande
mi ha sempre molto incuriosito e
spaventato allo stesso tempo la
consapevolezza che all'uomo dei propri
limiti e forse è proprio questo senso di
angoscia che ci spinge a guardare avanti
ci spinge a decidere che i limiti stanno
dove noi decidiamo di porli il mare il
mare al punto di partenza della nostra
storia
e strano come in molti racconti alcuni
particolari siano ricorrenti il mare nei
secoli è sempre stato uno dei motori che
ha spinto l'uomo verso la scoperta verso
l'esplorazione
e continua a farlo anche oggi
di fronte a un'immensa distesa d'acqua
il nostro occhio pool di vostri occhi
possono solo immaginare cosa si nasconda
al di là dell'orizzonte uno spazio senza
limiti senza confini che ci
costringerete creativi
pensateci bene tra tutti i paesaggi che
conosciamo possiamo dire che il mare è
senza dubbio quello più misterioso ed
inesplorato
il mare tutti aspetti a notevoli
similitudini quello spazio lo spazio al
vuoto il nulla
sia l'astronauta che subacqueo si
ritrovano a dover sopravvivere in un
ambiente a loro stile non è un caso
infatti che la nasa abbiano i programmi
delle esercitazioni che si svolgano
proprio sott'acqua
il nostro pianeta è composto per oltre
il 70 per cento d'acqua del restante 30
per cento delle terre emerse solo il 10
6 per cento e superficie arabile
dagli anni 50 ad oggi
desertificazione espansione urbana
inquinamento
tutto questo ha contribuito e direi sta
contribuendo
a ridurre ulteriormente la nostra
disponibilità di terre
la fao stima che nei prossimi 20 30 anni
il nostro pianeta avrà bisogno del 50
per cento in più di cibo del 45 per
cento in più di energia ed il 30 per
cento in più di acqua dolce per sfamare
per sostenere una popolazione mondiale
stimata di 9 miliardi forse anche di più
quindi
quindi più persone
meno terra
maggiore richiesta di cibo
si tratta di un problema serio che
riguarda ognuno di noi ma che come
capita spesso per cerchiamo distante non
c'è sempre occupiamo noi cerchiamo
soluzioni tangibili attuabili nella
quotidianità
la domanda è cosa pensiamo di fare
ci limiteremo a distruggere ed esaurire
le risorse che abbiamo e vogliamo
trovare una soluzione
se guardiamo abbastanza in profondità
c'è sempre una soluzione ci sono tante
potenzialità che aspettano solo di
essere svelate
un'idea folle conoscete il concetto di
serendipità
serendipità il trovare qualcosa che non
state cercando per puro caso
così
avete presente quando facendo giorno
dopo giorno allo stesso tragitto
improvvisamente vedete qualcosa di nuovo
sotto i vostri occhi qualcosa che è
sempre stato lì ma di cui non ve ne
siete mai resi conto nulla è cambiato ma
è il vostro sguardo ad essere diverso
a noi è capitato questo seduti
a noli liguria osservare il nostro
bellissimo mare
siamo stati colti all'improvviso da
un'idea folle
abbiamo pensato
non possiamo trovare una soluzione
alternativa
ma soprattutto sostenibile in un pianeta
che è composto per oltre il 70 per cento
d'acqua
siamo convinti che
l'innovazione e il progresso però si
possono attuare solo se diamo
diamo forma ai nostri sogni alle nostre
idee
idee che magari sembrano totalmente
pazzi e bizzarre ma che poi in qualche
modo si concretizzano bisogna solo
tentare provare e accettare le sfide
accettare anche le sfide che sembrano
impossibili
la visione prende forma fatti e così è
nato il primo sistema di agricoltura
subacquea una piccola piccolo
laboratorio per
sperimentare appunto le le piante che
abbiamo qua
sott'acqua però
anche se ad essere sinceri i primi
esperimenti sono stati molto casalinghi
siamo possiamo dire cosi frattini
moscardi ne è nato così un piccolo
palloncino una piccola cupola in un
acquario poi replicato in grandi
dimensioni in mare
come in una missione spaziale
esistono dei tempi da rispettare anche
nella missione subacquea ci sono dei
tempi sbaglio o si deve portare dietro
l'atmosfera per poter sopravvivere
a pensarci bene stato proprio come fare
un primo passo su un pianeta nuovo the
net a scoprire dove ogni giorno è una
sfida dove ogni giorno nella rivelazione
ma vi immaginate la sensazione che
abbiamo provato la prima volta quando ci
siamo tolti la maschera 10 metri
sott'acqua
abbiamo fatto il primo respiro ritiro
inebriante a pieni polmoni un'aria nuova
che mai nessuno prima di noi aveva
respirato
vi posso solo dire che in quello spazio
così angusto ci sentivamo un po folli e
l'eco delle risate rimbombava fortissimo
un nuovo orizzonte
lo ammetto da qui non è facile non è
facile abituare lo sguardo ad un nuovo
orizzonte da quale osservare il mondo
ci si sente strani ci si sente un po
come poco in un acquario però al
contrario
in questa condizione ci siamo trovati
euforici liberi senza confini intorno a
noi consapevoli di aver fatto un primo
passo verso un cambiamento radicale
questo stato l'inizio è stato un nuovo
inizio
nel momento in cui ci siamo immersi in
questo in questo mondo ci siamo resi
conto che non potevamo che non volevamo
più guardare indietro
adesso ad alcuni di voi verrà da pensare
che sia stato un gioco eccentrico e
potenzialmente molto dispendioso ma
realtà non è così la missione del
progetto infatti era essere
autosostenibili quindi essere in grado
di creare un sistema che si
autoalimentasse noi l'energia
apprendiamo dal sole e dal vento quindi
prendiamo l'energia da un qualcosa che è
già intorno a noi e poi che fosse un
sistema
ecologico e quindi pienamente integrato
nell'ambiente facendo sì che la natura
stessa potesse trarre dei benefici
facendo sì che il mare e tra esse dei
benefici creando delle strutture nei
quali la vita potesse potesse crescere
vi chiederete perché coltivare
sott'acqua
la risposta che in natura ogni cosa
intrecciata
domandiamoci più che altro di che cosa
hanno bisogno le piante per vivere
le piante ha bisogno di quattro fattori
principali le piante era bisogno di
stabilità termica
naturalmente le piante hanno bisogno di
luce per effettuare la fotosintesi
le piante hanno bisogno di acqua dolce
questa è una grande scoperta
e ultimo ma certamente non meno
importante le piante hanno bisogno di
protezione
dovrà essere protette da parassiti e da
agenti atmosferici in generale
ora questi quattro principi che possono
sembrare
semplici banali se presi così
singolarmente
non sono così facili realtà la trovare
nel nostro pianeta e soprattutto non
sono condizioni certe scalabili e
replicabili
pensiamo in realtà questi quattro
semplici principi li possiamo trovare
sott'acqua
la scoperta entusiasmante è stata senza
dubbio rendersi conto di riuscire ad
ottenere l'acqua dolce dall'acqua salata
la biosfera infatti è riempita d'aria e
i raggi che provengono dalla superficie
dal sole
la riscalda l'acqua salata evapora e
condensa all'interno della superficie
della biosfera ottenendo l'acqua dolce
necessaria le piante per per vivere per
crescere e per alimentare la tecnologia
idroponica che è alla base del nostro
progetto un altro grande beneficio è la
stabilità termica infatti l'acqua è un
grandissimo serbatoio di energia
il mare a una temperatura stabile tra il
giorno e la notte e permette queste
permette alle piante di crescere inoltre
le biosfere siano messi sott'acqua il
mare crea una barriera naturale contro
insetti parassiti
questi sono i principi alla base del
nostro progetto
dal giorno in cui abbiamo inserito
quella cupola in un acquario né moscarda
ne ha fatto passi da gigante anno dopo
anno il 2015 abbiamo partecipato
all'expo di milano rappresentando la
nostra regione la liguria e questo ci ha
permesso di avere una buona visibilità
ha permesso al progetto di crescere ed
espandersi
poi il 2020 storia recente gov.it non
devo aggiungere altro direi
dopo tanta fatica anche il nostro orto è
rimasto e lock down in balia degli
eventi
abbandonato a se stesso
pensavamo a tutto il nostro lavoro tutta
la fatica
christie's di settimana settimana
vedevamo deteriorarsi lo spessore delle
alghe sulle biosfere scandiva il passare
dei giorni
ci siamo troppo difficoltà
certo non era la prima volta ma questa
volta le possibilità che il progetto
potesse continuare diventano davvero
limitate quasi nulle
un giorno però abbiamo visto la speranza
abbiamo visto la vita aggrapparsi a un
raggio di sole e continuare ciò che noi
avevamo solo iniziato una piantina di
basi di basilico a ridarci la fiducia la
fiducia di una ritrovata normalità
che tutti noi ci potevamo augurare
ma c'è una storia particolare che ha
pesato nella nostra decisione di
continuare
una favola che abbiamo ricevuto durante
la brawn da un bambino di noli
questo bimbo racconta che un giorno
scoppia una pandemia che costrinse tutto
il mondo a richiudersi in casa e tutte
le persone stavano impazzendo
nessuno però si preoccupava dei bambini
che avevano perso tutte le loro passioni
quel bimbo però non si demoralizzava
improvvisamente si ricordò del basilico
coltivato sott'acqua andiamo garden
una notte sfido alla quarantena andò a
prenderlo è arrivato a casa come scola
quell'acqua creò un intruglio che nei
blitz o per per l'aria e da quel giorno
nel mondo non si registrano più casi di
questo virus tutti festeggiarono e tutti
guarirono ora a molti di voi verrà da
sorridere è arrivati a questo punto vi
chiederete qual è lo scopo del progetto
ce ne sono tanti ne abbiamo scoperti
sempre di più lungo la strada
da buon genovese mi verrebbe da dire può
esistere forse un futuro senza basilico
in realtà crediamo profondamente
fermamente che in un pianeta che è
composto per oltre 70 per cento d'acqua
è naturale che il futuro della
sostenibilità possa e debba passare per
gli oceani
dovremo cercare di risolvere i problemi
con quello che abbiamo qui cercano di
essere creativi originali
ci immaginiamo un domani che questa
tecnologia queste due sfere possano
contribuire
a fornire cibo in quelle posti del mondo
dove mancano di carrara bile dove non
hanno l'acqua dolce dove non hanno
infrastrutture
né moscardini molto di più che la nuova
tecnologia è molto di più che un
attrazione turistica è molto di più che
un riparo per centinaia di creature
marine demos garden è la realizzazione
di un sogno
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]